[Music]
it's easy to become numb to media bias
these days so the ingram angle
we're keeping track of the worst
offenders of the week
joining me now is adam gillette
president of accuracy and media and lisa
booth fox news contributor great to see
you both um
now the left guys they they love coming
after you know alex jones you know he's
the poster boy for just being
you know out of his gourd but he doesn't
have a prime time
show at a major network last time i
checked so we want to begin this edition
of worst in media with the insanity
that was joy reid this week watch
the police are the employees of the
citizens they're protecting and serving
the glob money off of these communities
by having people write tickets
black communities of brown communities
are literally paying the police to kill
them
if there was a you know a restaurant
chain uh that killed a certain
percentage
of its customers you wouldn't say well
you know that one cook was good
but at least the rest of the you know
that one cook was bad but the rest of
them are good
fines are funding the police and their
pensions
to then turn around and kill people for
nothing this
is micaiah bryant just 16 years old
looking at very much
like 16 year olds do doing her hair in
the tutorials she once posted on tick
tock looking adorable
i remember fights in even high school or
even younger than that where
a kid brought a pen knife or something
to school and teachers were able to
defuse that and they'd have guns
no one's asking what would have scared a
kid who's in a foster situation
so much that she felt that she needed to
defend herself or
pick up a knife now she's for
weapons and self-defense okay well lisa
now
imagine if any conservative said
something
just like i don't know a quarter as
inflammatory
uh about uh another situations facts
kind of similar
let alone someone who has a prime time
show reaction
yeah i mean laura i remember my first
knife fight don't you i mean this is
insanity but look she's long been
she's long been insane and what did
msnbc do they said you know what
you're perfect you're getting the 7 p.m
show but it's such a liberal privilege
because if any conservative said half of
the crazy things she did they would be
canned
off air and completely canceled but
she's got the 7 p.m so there you go
yeah well she'll probably get bumped up
to the 10 p.m soon because don't central
here all right adam speaking of joy yeah
exactly speaking of joy reid
one of her guests gave an excuse for
the black teenager who was shot and
killed by the police in columbus now
remember the girl was shot as she
attempted
to slash and stab someone
if that is the standard then no black
person is really truly going to be safe
if we cannot be having a bad day if we
cannot defend ourselves and we think we
are going to get jumped makaya bryant
was a child
like tamir rice was a child people just
see her as the aggressor they don't see
her humanity
they have adultified her
did she say adultified i don't know what
she said there but
it wasn't a word adam but she was just
apparently having a bad
day the assailant yeah you know who was
having a bad day the young girl who was
about to have a knife
thrust into her and as a reminder i
thought they wanted to let 16 year olds
vote
i thought they were supposed to be
adults they say oh
no she's only viewed as an aggressor
again i think the girl who is about to
have blade
shoved into her body certainly viewed
her as the aggressor it's outrageous
lisa i want to take um on another aspect
of this
media malfeasance and it has to do with
covid one of our favorite topics here on
the angle
now if you thought that biden was kind
of dr doom
over all the july 4th gatherings waiting
to hear what the former fda commissioner
scott gottlieb said
about next christmas
coronaviruses are typically late winter
pathogens they circulate in december
january
and this is going to transition this
year probably from more of a pandemic
straight into a seasonal stranger i
don't think we're going to be having
holiday parties in
you know the back room of a crowded
restaurant in december 20th
we should just start asking them you
know are we going to have christmas in
like 2025
or rose parade in 2027 unbelievable
yeah yeah i mean can we can we ever live
our lives again i mean these people want
us to
to put on hazmat suits and hide in our
basements in perpetuity
for the rest of our lives so that they
can extend their 15 minutes of fame
into 20 because this isn't what's best
for the american people this isn't
what's best for americans
and their words have consequences but
they don't care because they get to put
their face on tv
just like dr fauci and he gets to throw
out the first pitch at the washington
nationals game
and it's all just fine and dandy for
them or if you have a
on the board of one of our major drug
companies i believe a advisor
scott gottlieb is maybe have other
reasons for wanting to push
this kind of paranoia and it certainly
yeah and it certainly leads to vaccine
hesitancy if you don't get your life
back what's the point of the vaccine
now to most uh americans guys maxine
waters stoking uh the racial violence we
said that saw that ahead of the shaving
trial
was just disgusting but not to pbs's
resident agitator yamiche alcindor
because
she eagerly came to auntie maxine's
defense
i wonder why the white house isn't also
coming to the defense of representative
waters given
the fact that she's now facing an
onslaught of attacks especially but i
would say republicans
she was obviously not threatening
violence
adam here is where we remind viewers uh
they pay
yamiche's salary at least in part with
the pbs
connection well that's exactly right for
years we've bemoaned at accuracy and
media
that pbs is a leftist news organization
now they're clearly a leftist activist
organization and to your point
the government takes our money by force
to fund
a leftist activist alleged news
organization and it's amazing how far
the civil rights movement has gone if
what she says is true
because martin luther king he dreamed of
a colorblind society
where we would judge one another based
on the content of our character
if martin luther king was around today
he'd be canceled these are crazy
radicals
and they're doing it with our tax
dollars
and they're they're not reporters
anymore lisa they're they're
agitators they they're saying why are
you saying this and
joe why aren't you doing this and why
aren't you getting rid of the filibuster
i mean these are
these are like you know these are like
board meetings where the
where the board uh members are being uh
absolutely assaulted by shareholders
meaning the press
telling them we want you to buy this
company the pressure being put on
politicians
by the media well and they're better
spokespeople than
jen saki is for the democratic party and
like we we no longer have
a media in america laura i mean they're
just propagandas
an extension of the democrat party and
they're more focused
on pushing narratives than the facts as
we've seen with this recent incident
in ohio that they're trying to normalize
knife fights and also trying to condemn
a white police officer who saved a young
black woman's life
adam lisa thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else